extrait
[musique]
1er étage
elle s'est noyée
[musique]
il a été annulé vicki benson
câbles
[musique]
[applaudissements]
jusqu'à présent, nous installons échoue
réparer une partie fiable du sous-marin
Je pense malheureusement qu'il y a des victimes et
beaucoup
[applaudissements]
[musique]
et mes Indiens ne font pas non plus peur aux laitières
sortir la version traîneau de kristoff juste une minute
somme je serai le temps des classes marchandes
[musique]
se précipiter indéfiniment à travers les haut-parleurs
et là ils ont laissé Alyonka toute seule
augmentation de frs sur la nourriture allons y en bateau
[musique]
mon avis est que se reposer sur l'azur
là-bas pendant cette période
le commandant en chef ne devrait pas avoir
[musique]
Nous
vous du tout sur sa salade de vous dans une colonne
information ligne plate à droite
20 ans black & thai
[musique]
mettre toute honte à la nation et à tous
événements qui se produisent chaque
le fait que Poutine cessera bientôt de croire
parce que